Вже за лічені дні ці пакунки відправлять на фронт.
Їх понад місяць усією країною збирають для військових ЗСУ, аби навіть в бліндажі
та окопи прийшло Різдво.
За цей час у поштовому відділенні містечка Полонне, що на Хмельниччині, роботи додалося.
Подарунки для українських захисників щодня надходять десятками.
Кожні три дні ми стабільно приїжджаємо на "Нову пошту", щоб забрати подарунки.
Стабільно ми отримуємо в районі 30 пакунків, а сьогодні, наприклад, отримали 46.
Цього разу пакунків настільки багато, що в одну машину вони не помістилися.
Тож автівка знімальної групи DW теж стала в пригоді.
З відділення пошти усі коробки везуть на імпровізований склад.
Спочатку їх збирали в приватному будинку волонтерів, утім дуже швидко там стало тісно.
Тепер подарунки для військових зберігають в будівлі міськради.
Тут їх готують до відправки на фронт.
Майже в кожній коробці - медикаменти.
Різноманітні знеболювальні та протизастудні надсилають за запитом військових,
але "таємні Санти" додають дещо й від себе.
- Так, це ліки. "Німесил" ми бачимо та… "Аскорбінка".
- Загалом вам часто присилають ліки, вітаміни?
- Так, дуже часто. Хлопці замовляють певні ліки, але бачу, що ще додатково
кладуть якісь вітамінки, смаколики.
Загалом в рамках акції "таємним Сантою" для військових ЗСУ стали близько 5 тисяч українців.
Серед основних запитів від воїнів зовсім не святкові, а навпаки - буденні та суто воєнні речі.
Ось, приміром, український захисник замовив на Різдво… турнікети.
Це турнікет. Дуже класна, дуже потрібна річ нашим хлопцям. Бачу ще один турнікет.
Перш за все, це їхнє життя.
Ну звичайно, повна коробка смаколиків. Як я можу це не показати?
Тож кожен запит на подарунок - не примха, а радше необхідність.
Зараз насамперед потрібні бушлати, теплі штани, зимові берці, щоб не було холодно, грілки.
Тобто все, що може зігріти, зараз необхідне. Звісно, є якісь інші речі, якісь засоби гігієни,
якесь печиво люди можуть покласти, листівку.
Це все збадьорить, але насправді в пріоритеті цей теплий одяг, який буде гріти.
І хоча військові просять на Різдво лише найнеобхідніше, серед зібраних подарунків
є чимало книг та настільних ігор. У таких спосіб українці турбуються про дозвілля захисників.
О-о, знов, дівчата, книга! "Таємниця старого Лами". Клас!
Військові такого насправді не просили, але коли ми отримували пакунки й відкривали їх,
то дуже-дуже багато було подарунків, де люди від себе купували книги,
різні ігри й докладали в подарунки.
Та найзворушливіше у кожному пакунку - листи та дитячі малюнки.
Коли я читала, то я просто не могла стримати сліз.
Я думаю, що нашим військовим буде надзвичайно приємно.
"Дякую, що даєте нам можливість жити. Коли ви повернетеся, а те падло здохне,
ми будемо робити все можливе, щоб ви себе комфортно почували.
Ви великі молодці, ми вас всіх чекаємо додому. Ми вас любимо! Ви - найкрутіші!"
Запити на різдвяні подарунки "Український жіночий батальйон"
збирав від військових і підрозділів напряму.
Ми працюємо винятково з офіційними запитами, впродовж усієї нашої діяльності є перелік військових
і військових частин, з якими ми взаємодіємо. Коли ми запускали цю акцію, ми написали їм:
"Якщо у вас є якась потреба, яку ви хочете, щоб ми закрили, то дайте нам список".
Власне, вони формували. Наразі у нас по "чеклісту" 20 підрозділів.
Кожен із цих підрозділів має від 10 до 200-300 позицій.
Усі запити сформовані в єдиний довжелезний перелік.
Як тільки на склад привозять нову партію пакунків - волонтери одразу беруться за роботу,
адже кожен подарунок має потрапити в потрібні руки.
Ми сортуємо саме по конкретній людині. У нас на кожній посилці є цифри.
Люди, коли надсилають, ставлять цифри, які показують, для кого саме посилка. Тобто посилка типу іменна.
На сортування кожної нової партії подарунків намагається знаходити час пані Людмила.
Для неї це не лише можливість бути корисною для українських захисників, а й спосіб заспокоєння.
Адже всі її найближчі чоловіки нині на війні.
У мене чоловік військовий. Він з 2014 року на фронті. На сьогодні він теж у зоні бойових дій.
У мене син з перших днів війни був на фронті. У мене зять теж з 2014 року на фронті.
Це те, що я можу сказати особисто про себе.
Також для того, аби закрити усі потреби військових, "Український жіночий батальйон"
створив спеціальний збір. Завдяки пожертвам небайдужих планують придбати якісний теплий одяг,
який часом по вартості непідйомний навіть для найбільш небайдужих "таємних Сант".
Наприклад, одні берці хороші коштують від 11 тисяч гривень. Тобто це одне взуття.
А їх треба пар 60. Наприклад, один костюм - 17 тисяч коштує куртка та низ коштує ще 10 тисяч.
Це насправді дорогий одяг, але ми розуміємо, що він якісний.
Усі подарунки на фронт організатори акції обіцяють доставити вчасно - до Різдва,
яке цьогоріч Україна офіційно святкуватиме 25 грудня.